What do you think happens with him?
I don't know who can today.
I don't know who can beat him.
Who Do you think can beat him?
That's a good question.
I Dunno. Hillary can't,
I'm so worried.
Yeah,
but I'm so worried she's going to run
again and she's going to muscle her way to
the top. I don't know who can
beat him right now and I'm, I'm,
I don't know. Why do you think
that in the question, right?
If things keep going
further and further south,
what about someone who
was a centrist Democrat?
Doesn't that make more sense that someone
who's gonna, who's a rational person,
who's on the right is going to look at
this person who's maybe a economically
conservative but socially liberal and say,
this is really where I'm leaning towards
the one on the far left and like on,
on an identity politics platform,
right. It scares me. Yeah.
That's not going to work. Well, it
could it though, because I think so.
I don't know. Because Trump's
whole thing was, screw the center.
I just need to make my base
go ape shit crazy for me.
But there's still apeshit crazy and no
matter what he does and I'm worried that
the left the Democrats are going to try
and replicate that strategy and be like,
we just need to make our base go ape shit
crazy rather than running someone that
can win the center.
I see where you're going,
but I think that this is
maybe my liberal bias,
but I think that people on the
left wouldn't fall for that.
The same way people on the right would,
I don't think people on the left who saw
someone who went ape shit full woke far
left. I think there's a lot of
people in the center and be like,
well I'm going to just get a vote,
libertarian man.
I'm going to vote for Gary Johnson or some
shit. But okay, so who's in right now?
So we have Kamala Kirsten Gillibrand
months dress monster ts ideas.
Well, when she was 22 she had,
oh she isn't a solid toady.
What does that mean? She is
a toady. I think that I use
that word correctly. Jamie,
can you check with toady means like towing
the line? Is that what it means? No,
I think it's like a
t o a d I. E was, I mean,
okay.
I think it means that.
I think it means
there you go.
Toady definition of toadies, a person
confess flowers or defers to others.
Can they kind of self serving
reasons I stick a fan.
So she's an Assad sick offense. Is that
what you're saying? Yeah, that's, that's
okay.
Known about her. Like what did she say
that, oh, we have to look. I don't,
I don't remember the details.
I probably should say that
before we say that about,
or we should probably read it rather
well. I have read it. Not many.
Maybe we should, right? Oh yeah.
Okay. Just so we know what she said.
I've had her on Gab or really enjoy
talking to her. I like her a lot.
Are you serious? Yeah. Like talking
to her. A lot of talking to her.
I don't know about, I think she's like
the mother lode of bad ideas. Whoa.
I'm pretty positive about that. Especially
on the side. But maybe I'm wrong.
I don't think I'm wrong.
Well,
my take on her was that I think as
a person who's coming from the left,
who's also a veteran and uh, it's very
articulate and sensible and a woman,
and in talking to her, and we didn't
get into a sod or any of those things,
but talking to her about what she feels
is wrong with the current administration
and the way things are running in a
direction she thinks things could go in.
She has a very promising ideas. I don't,
I didn't know about it. It doesn't,
she also, did she ever apologize for
believing in conversion therapy for,
I didn't even know she
believed in conversion therapy.
Am I crazy? Is that real?
I'm almost positive this is real.
I think her father ran con.
When you say conversion therapy, you're
talking about gay people. Yeah. No,
I didn't know that.
I never heard that.
And I did hear something about when
she was very young, she was like 22.
She had said something about
gay marriage and civil unions.
If she apologized for and
said that she evolved,
she reveals she met Assad in Syria without
informing top Democrats. Yeah. She's,
she said she went on a fact finding
mission in supportive piece for Syrian
people, but characterize us
backed rebels' as terrorists.
Okay.
Yeah.
She's,
I mean,
I can keep looking,
but I just,
I'm telling you the time to research
everything all at the same time.
I can come back on when I do. Well, let's,
let's, we can do this another time. Okay.
But what,
who do you think stands out for you as
someone that would make a good president?
Yeah. She wants touted working
for an anti gay group that,
that conversion therapy. Anyway, she
wants touted working for an anti,
she worked for an anti gay group. She
worked for them, like she had a job there.
You know, I'm worried as a person who's
been called. All right. Uh, Jason,
I'm just looking at about labels. No,
I understand. But you know what I mean?
Rep Tulsi Galbard in the early two
thousands touted working for her father's
anti gay organization,
which mobilized to pass a measure
against same sex marriage in Hawaii and
perverted and promoted controversial
conversion therapy. Yeah.
FYI.